N
NUCLEAR REACTOR, TO MAKE FUEL,
FOR NUCLEAR BOMBS.
THE HEIGHTENED TENSIONS BETWEEN
MAINLAND CHINA, AND TAIWAN, ARE
PUTTING THE U.S. IN A TOUGH
POSITION.
IT COULD BECOME A MAJOR TEST
FOR THE PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN.
BEIJING, CALLING FOR A PEACEFUL,
REUNIFICATION WITH TAIWAN.
BUT, IN RECENT, WEEKS IT SAID
THAT DOZENS OF MILITARY
AIRCRAFT INTO THE ISLANDS AIR
DEFENSE IDENTIFICATION ZONE.
MEANWHILE, TAIWAN REMAINS
DEFIANT, WITH ITS PRESIDENT
SAYING, THE ISLAND WILL NOT BOW
TO PRESSURE.
ON WEDNESDAY, CHINA'S MILITARY
RELEASE THIS VIDEO, SHOWING
MILITARY DRILLS AND FUJIAN
PROVINCE, DIRECTLY ACROSS FROM
TAIWAN.
THE EXACT DATE, WHEN THEY TOOK
PLACE, IS NOT KNOWN.
BUT, WILL RIPLEY HAS THE STORY.
WELL?
>> TAIWAN'S GROWING ARSENAL ARE
ON FULL DISPLAY, AT THIS
WEEKEND'S NATIONAL DAY PARADE.
TO DEFEND AGAINST A GROWING
THREAT FROM CHINA, THIS SMALL
ISLAND IS SPENDING BIG ON
WATKINS.
MADE ME, MADE, IN THE USA.
>> F 16 FIGHTERS, PATRIOT
MISSILES, 5 BILLION DOLLARS IN
U.S. WEAPONS, SOLD TO TAIWAN,
LAST YEAR.
TAIWAN ARM SALES SKYROCKETING,
DURING THE TRUMP YEARS.
THE FORMER PRESIDENTS HARD-LINE
STANCE AGAINST CHINA, ONE OF
THE FEW TRUMP ERA POLICIES,
EMBRACED BY PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN.
DEFENDING TAIWAN'S DEMOCRACY
AGAINST AUTHORITARIAN CHINA HAS
RARE, BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SOME, WORRYING, WASHINGTON
POLITICS MAYBE PROVOKING
BEIJING.
EVEN, PUSHING TAIWAN.
AND, THE U.S., INTO DANGEROUS
TERRITORY.
>> IF YOU TAKE STEPS TO LOOK
LIKE YOU ARE, AGGRESSIVELY,
DEFENDING TAIWAN, ARGUABLY, YOU
PUT THEM IN A MORE VULNERABLE
POSITION.
ARGUABLY, YOU IRRITATE CHINA.
>> TAIWAN'S PRESIDENT, SAYING,
THE ISLAND IS ON THE FRONT
LINES OF A MUCH BIGGER BATTLE.
>> FREE, AND DEMOCRATIC
COUNTRIES, HAVE BEEN ALLERGIC
TO THE EXPANSION OF
AUTHORITARIANISM.
TAIWAN IS ON THE FOREFRONT OF,
THE DEFENSE LINE, A FELLOW
DEMOCRACIES.
>> CHINA SENT A RECORD 150
WARPLANES NEAR TAIWAN, IN JUST
5, DAYS THIS MONTH.
BUTTONS BALANCING ACT, COMING
ACROSS STRAIGHT TENSIONS,
DEFENDING DEMOCRACY, AND
PREVENTING A CONFLICT, THAT
COULD COST AMERICAN LIVES.
>> I SPOKE WEDGIE ABOUT TAIWAN.
>> I THINK, TAIWAN, PRESENTS A
CHALLENGE TO ANY AMERICAN
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION.
BECAUSE, YOU ARE TRYING TO
BALANCE COMPETING INTERESTS.
>> THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
SIGHT.
4 KINDS OF DOMESTICALLY
PRODUCED MISSILES, ROLLING
THROUGH THE CAPITAL, IN FRONT
OF TAIWAN'S PRESIDENTIAL
PALACE.
AN OMINOUS SIGN OF ESCALATING,
REGIONAL TENSIONS.
>> WE CANNOT CONTROL WHETHER OR
NOT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
HAS THE ABILITY TO ATTACK
TAIWAN.
BUT, WE ARE ABLE TO CONTROL,
AND MAKE, SURE IT DOESN'T HAVE
THE MOTIVATION TO DO SO.
>> EVERY CHINESE LEADER, SINCE
MAE, HAS VOWED TO TAKE CONTROL
OF TAIWAN.
ANALYSTS SAY, PRESIDENT XI
JINPING MAYBE THE FIRST, WHERE
THE MILITARY, MIGHTY ENOUGH, TO
DO IT.
EVEN AS HE CALLS FOR PEACEFUL
REUNIFICATION.
>> WHOEVER WINS TAIWAN, WINS
THE WORLD.
>> CHINA IS LOCKED IN
TERRITORIAL PURSUITS IN THE
INDO-PACIFIC REGION.
TAIWAN, BEIJING'S BIGGEST
UNRESOLVED ISSUE, AND SOME SAY,
BIDEN'S BIGGEST TEST.
WILL RIPLEY, CNN, TAIPEI
JOINING US NOW FROM TAIPEI IS
MICHAEL, COZY NEW FELLOW OF THE
GLOBAL TAIWAN INSTITUTE IN
WASHINGTON.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
IT IS CERTAINLY BEEN A WEEK
EVEN JUST THE LAST FEW DAYS
HAVE RATCHETING UP OF TENSIONS.
WHAT'S THE MOOD THERE RIGHT NOW
WHERE YOU ARE?
>> A VERY GOOD DEMEANOR.
THE MOOD IS THE TIME WHEN HE'S
ARE NOT EXACTLY NOT USED TO
THIS KIND OF SIGNALING AND
BEWILDERING IS COMING FROM
BEIJING.
IT HAS COMMON WAYS OVER THE
YEARS.
THE TIME WHEN THESE PEOPLE ARE
VERY PRAGMATIC.
THEY'RE RESILIENT.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT DESPITE
THE THREATS THAT THEY HAD SEEN
IN THE PAST 2 WEEKS OR SO, THAT
THEY ARE QUITE CONVINCED THAT
BEIJING IS READY TO GO THAT ONE
EXTRA STEP AND USE FORCE
AGAINST TAIWAN.
>> BECAUSE, CHINA HAS THE
ABILITY TO MILITARILY DO WHAT
IT ONCE.
IT'S A QUESTION OF WHETHER IT
HAS THE MOST VIVACIOUS IN,
THAT'S, YOU KNOW, WHERE DOES
SEE JINPING COME ON THAT?
>> IT'S REALLY HARD TO BE IN XI
JINPING'S SHOES.
BUT CERTAINLY, THE CHINESE HAVE
ACCUMULATED SUFFICIENT
CAPABILITIES, THAT NOW HAVE
REACHED THE POINT THAT IF THERE
YOU DECIDE TO MERGE THOSE
CAPABILITIES, WHICH THE
INTENTION OF USING FORCE THEY
WOULD BE IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION THAN THEY WERE JUST 20
YEARS AGO, FOR EXAMPLE.
MY MAIN FEAR IS THAT THE
DECISION TO LAUNCH HOSTILITIES
AGAINST TAIWAN WOULD BE MOSTLY
THE RESULT OF PRESSURES BACK IN
CHINA.
BUT IF THE IMPRESSION WERE
GREATER FOR TAIWAN TO MANY RED
LINES, OR THAT THE
INTERNATIONAL CONTEXT IS
CLEARLY SHIFTING IN TAIWAN'S
FAVOR.
THIS COULD EVENTUALLY LEAD TO
WAR, AND WOULD SEEM TO BE
IRRATIONAL BEHAVIOR ON THE PART
OF BEIJING.
SPENDING WILL LIKELY CAUSE OF
THE --
REGION WOULD NEVERTHELESS
INITIATE THE HOSTILITIES.
POSSIBLY THROWING COUNTRIES
LIKE JAPAN AND OTHER REGIONAL
POWERS.
>> YEAH.
THAT IS CERTAINLY THE
WORST-CASE SCENARIO.
AND NO DOUBT, THAT IS BEING
DIGESTED IN WASHINGTON AS WELL.
WILL RIPLEY'S PIECE THERE
SUGGESTED THAT PERHAPS THIS
INCREASE AND INCREASE IN SALES
5 BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
WEAPONS SOLD JUST LAST YEAR TO
THE TIE WITH KNEES, THAT IS A
WAY PERHAPS TO PROVOKE BEIJING,
BREAKING THE BEARER AS SUCH?
>> WHATEVER TAIWAN DOES THAT
LEADS TO SOVEREIGNTY AND
INTERACTIONS WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
WE WILL ALWAYS BE SEEN AS
PROVOCATIVE BY BEIJING.
AND WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE
DECADES THAT CHINA WAS VERY
GOOD AT CONDITIONING
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY INTO
RISK AVOIDANCE.
SO WHAT WE SAW DURING THESE
LONG PERIODS DURING WHICH
UNITED STATES WOULD SIMPLY NOT
SELL A MUNITIONS TO TAIWAN FOR
FEAR THAT WOULD UNDERMINE THEIR
ABILITY WITH BEIJING.
NOW UNDER PRESIDENT SHE, THE
NATIONALISM IN CHINA HAS BEEN
THE IDEOLOGY IS SUCH.
BUT THERE'S AWAKENING,
CERTAINLY IN PLACES LIKE
WASHINGTON D.C. OR ELSEWHERE,
THAT NO MATTER WHAT WE GIVE, IT
WILL NEVER BE ENOUGH FOR THEM.
SO NOW, WE ARE ENTERING A NEW
PHASE WHERE, AGAIN THE, UNITED
STATES STAKING THE LEAD OF
OTHER COUNTRIES, AND THEY'RE
DECIDING TO ENGAGE TAIWAN TO
HELP DEFEND DEMOCRACY, AND HELP
DEFEND FRONTLINE STATES IN A
GROWING WAR OF IDEOLOGIES.
AND SEEING HOW WAGING WILL
REACT.
BUT MORE OFTEN THAN NOT,
BEIJING WILL EXPRESS DISCONTENT,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME REALIZES
THAT STRICTLY TAKING ON NATURE
NATIONAL COMMUNITY, OR EVEN THE
QUESTION OF DEMOCRACY COULD
HAVE KIND OF CATASTROPHIC
IMPACT FOR THE CHINESE ECONOMY,
TRYING TO SPENDING IN THE
WORLD.
SO IT WILL BACKFIRE.
SO THIS IS A BACK AND FORTH --
>> SO, HOW IS BIDEN GAMING THIS
OUT?
HE'S HOPING THAT --
>> WILL BIDEN IS --
IS >> THAT LIKELY?
>> THIS IS A GAMBLE.
WE ARE AN UNKNOWN TERRITORY.
AGAIN, THE ASSUMPTION THAT AT
THE END OF THE ROAD, BEIJING
WOULD ACT RATIONALLY.
WOULD CALCULATE THE RISKS AND
BENEFITS OF TAKING DRASTIC
ACTION IN THE TAIWAN STRAIGHT.
WE OBVIOUSLY CANNOT PREDICT THE
FUTURE, AND THAT IS WHY
BOLSTERING DETERRENCE AGAINST
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT CHINA WOULD
DECIDE TO TAKE THAT ONE EXTRA
STEP IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL.
TAIWAN HAS A ROLE TO PLAY.
DIFFERENT WEAPONS SYSTEM, BUT
ALSO THE MORE COUNTRIES WITHIN
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY,
NOT JUST MILITARILY, BUT ALSO
POLITICALLY AND ECONOMICALLY,
PROMISE A COUNTERVAILING ACTION
AGAINST CHINA IF IT ATTACKED
TAIWAN.
SHOULD CONTRIBUTED TO TERRENCE
AND THEREFORE REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT CHINA WOULD
DECIDE TO ATTACK TAIWAN.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.